my first guest tonight is the afternoon
Drivetime disc jockey on WNBC please
welcome America's worst nightmare the
one the only Howard Stern why'd you come
out we have a lot of laughs together but
over the years who can forget the time I
comb Dave's hair with my feet you loved
it I took my smelly feet and started
combing Dave's head whereas deep enough
Stiles you're here tonight
this will probably be my last appearance
Howard has announced he will not be back
on the show it's too much pressure doing
this show I didn't want to come on my
parents are gonna be watching my fans
are gonna be watching what if I'm not
funny what if I suck why is the pressure
on me this is Dave's pressure if I suck
it's your fault the producer calls me up
and says what are you gonna talk to
David about stupid NBC censors think the
word orgasm is not proper for television
you don't think we're too uptight about
our own sexuality I do I wear condoms
what do you wear I masturbate that's
enough having smelly gentlemen I can't
live a lie no Howard saying orgasm will
that stay in the show I always you get
along well with the management NBC radio
it's worse than ever see I'm gonna get
fired for talking about this I know it
say you don't care do you
no I don't care I am very glad to be
done with NBC welcome to the CBS family
yeah it's like the Manson Family show
business weasels I used to work for
Viacom CBS like you you had your scandal
Charlie Sheen has his scandal they keep
hiring you guys me I get fired
backstage looking over everyone and said
did you have sex with Dave no no no no
no you know I feel Dave put me on
national television many years ago
before I was known and I have stuck with
Dave how did you feel when Jay Leno was
chosen as the host of The Tonight Show
honestly this is the guy who would've
been hid in a closet yeah well the other
took away the shell from how long is Jay
Leno really have Jay is horrible I never
liked Jay I can't let me say something
Jay's got no talent he did tape raw I
would never go on The Tonight Show with
David Letterman for you I don't want the
same thing happening you happen to Regis
here's the host that we want to watch